[Music]
hello good afternoon my name is Miki
Kataria and welcome to the Android for
car session at Google i/o thank you it's
hard for me to believe that this is now
our sixth year at Google i/o talking
about Android and cars here is our first
time back in 2014 when we unveiled
Android auto on stage at Moscone in San
Francisco a fun fact from that day by
the way the sled that we had up on stage
was actually one of our first test Kia
Soul cars that we transformed
specifically for that purpose rest
assured it since found a happy home in
our team area where we still use it
every day for demos and testing even
before Android auto our investments and
commitments in the industry go back
almost 15 years at Google we know that
cars stay on the road for a very long
time and are an important part of
people's daily lives that's why over the
last decade we've continued to only
increase our investments and broaden our
partnerships with the automotive
industry when we expect that trend to
continue for the coming decade as well
one thing that's remained constant
throughout all of those years is our
vision and that is to bring a safe and
seamless connected experience into every
car a big part of making that experience
and this vision a reality is to have a
consistent reliable and extensible
platform like Android that enables us to
bring modern services easily into the
car with Android as an underlying
platform we think we can seamlessly
connect the users digital life from
outside of the car to what's happening
inside of the car what that means is the
same apps and services that you use on
your phones laptops other smart devices
those same apps and services can be
brought easily into the car with Android
as a shared underlying platform
and if we do our job well we think that
the experience in the car will be very
personalized and deeply integrated I've
personally had the opportunity to build
and shape many of the in-car products
that we brought to market over the years
and they've gone agone through three
three phases of investment we started
back in 2005 when we first worked with
Audi and VW to bring Google Earth into
their cars it's a great product it's
still on the road today many drivers
still going with it but the challenge
was taking a desktop app a client app
like Google Earth and porting it to run
on a proprietary platform that required
a lot of effort and we found it
virtually impossible to keep the
software up to date over time so we
pivoted in our second phase of
investment to a different approach we
started to open up cloud-based api's
primarily in maps and local so that
connected cars could pull in specific
features like Street View as shown here
and incorporate them and tie them into
the built in car navigation systems you
can see many of these cars on the road
today and from partners like Tesla BMW
Mercedes and many more and while the API
approach meant that we didn't have to
port any client software into cars what
we didn't anticipate was how ubiquitous
and common
smartphones would become over that
period of time so much so that drivers
were increasingly turning to familiar
and intuitive applications on their
phones even when they had access to
these in-car advanced navigation systems
so finally in our third and most recent
phase of investment what brings us here
today we looked at the phone strategy
and we saw how important it was to have
an Android as a common platform that
could enable us and developers
everywhere to bring services modern
services easily into the car and build
great up-to-date experiences and that is
how we started the effort to bring
Android into cars
one of the first investments behind in
car products is on the phone screen
itself with more than 1 billion cars on
the road today we know that the phone is
a part of many many drives already and
we want to do our part to make that
experience safer as well at the i/o
keynote this morning you heard about the
Google assistance driving mode here you
see it displayed in a dark theme this
driving mode is a new way to use your
phone in a safer and helpful way in your
car this project brings together the
best of designing for a driving
experience from several teams across
Google including the Android auto team
and it also represents the next step and
evolution of the Android auto phone
screen experience stay tuned for more
details as we migrate users from the
Android auto phone screen experience to
the Google assistance driving mode later
this year
beyond the phone screen we have two
major products for the car screen itself
the first is Android auto which we
unveiled in 2014 and launched to
consumers in 2015 this has Android auto
technology running on the phone and
integrating with compatible cars to
bring your favorite apps and services
directly to the car screen and then you
can interact with these apps and
services in a natural way using your
car's touchscreen rotary controller or
otherwise meanwhile all the software is
running on the phone it's exciting for
us to see that since 2015 Android auto
has become virtually an industry
standard and it's also humbling for us
to see that consumers will increasingly
not buy a new car if it ships without
Android auto the second major product
for the car screen is the Android
automotive OS this is Android running in
the car as the embedded entertainment
platform and it powers a a much deeper
more seamless experience for everything
from navigating with Google Maps to
listening to music with Spotify to
controlling vehicle functions like cabin
or seat temperature we can also enable
richer user experiences like showing
contextual visual maps as you see in the
cluster display here as infotainment
itself expands from being in one central
screen to multiple screens and gets more
deeply integrated into the car as well
and unlike Android auto your apps and
services are running on the car so it
doesn't matter what kind of phone you
have or even if you forgot your home
phone at home the name Android
automotive OS by the way is directed
primarily towards developers so that
they know the underlying platform for
which they're developing their services
is based on Android we think consumers
are more likely to notice familiar
brands that they already use on their
smart devices like Google Maps or I
Heart Radio or Spotify when they're in
the market looking at one of these cars
that's powered by Android under the hood
one of the questions that we sometimes
get when we talk about these two
projects side-by-side is is Android
automotive OS going to replace Android
auto the short answer is no we think
that both products both experiences will
continue to grow for a long time and
ultimately offer both users and our OEM
partners a choice in what to bring into
the car we also think that the phone in
the car will actually work together
better over time to create the best
experience possible for drivers and
passengers you can see some of that
today already as cars rely on phones for
things like making phone calls and we
think that experience will get better
and tighter so with that when you do
have your phone with you the entire
experience of the phone of the car
working together will be truly seamless
so with that I want to focus on Android
auto for a couple of minutes and talk
about the fantastic momentum that we've
been seeing over the last year and I'll
touch on how the momentum is coming
together through gross hardware and
software in terms of global reach
Android auto is available today in 36
markets we added five more markets in
the last few months and rest assured we
know that there are many more markets to
reach out there and we are working hard
to get into many many more of those by
in the coming months on the partnership
front Android auto is already available
in more than 500 car models from more
than 50 different brands earlier this
year
Toyota announced that they will be
shipping cars with Android auto from
later this year we are very very excited
to have them on board and working
together to reach more and more drivers
with Toyota on board nearly every major
global automotive OEM is now shipping
Android auto compatible cars and
together these committed partners
represent more than 95 percent of the
industry so thank you to our amazing
partners for helping us bring this a
fantastic safe and seamless experience
to every driver on the road Google i/o
would of course not exist without
developers and we've already seen
fantastic momentum here and it's one of
the great reasons for the success of
Android auto we're continuing to see
many many more apps join the Android
auto list of compatible apps and I just
want to highlight a few notable names
that have appeared over the last year
with our launch in South Korea we saw
local media apps bugs and melon support
Android auto and we also welcomed Apple
music YouTube music and Google podcasts
to the list of compatible apps thank you
to all the amazing developers for
helping make Android auto such a
fantastic experience for drivers out
there we have a dedicated session for
you also tomorrow morning where we talk
much more about how to build and adapt
your car your app for cars and we
continue to invest in making our
platform and enabling newer and better
experiences on top of the solid base
that we've already built together
all of these great partnerships and new
markets add up to one big number for us
we are on track to have Android auto in
more than 100 million cars in the next
year we are super proud and excited to
be able to get this far with all of your
support as I said in the beginning we
know that being an automotive requires a
long-term commitment
so getting from our first car in 2015 to
our hundred millionth car in 2020
hopefully shows you that we are here for
the long run switching to hardware
improvements that are allowing us to
reach more drivers we recently launched
support for a touchpad as an input
mechanism so if you have a car with one
of these devices you can now
effortlessly navigate the Android auto
UI we expect more of our partners to be
shipping touchpad in their cars so
enabling this now lets us reach more
drivers and more users and for more cars
starting today the wireless support
which we announced last year has been an
absolute game changer for how you use
this product you no longer have to take
the phone out of your pocket or your bag
and plug it in you can get in your car
and have Android auto or ready to go by
the time you want to drive we've already
seen great support from partners like
JVC Kenwood and Pioneer who have been
shipping aftermarket head units over the
last year and if you are in the market
for a new car you'll be excited to know
that the first cars with Android auto
wireless support built-in will be
shipping before the end of this year I'm
switching to software improvements we've
hit some pretty big milestones just
since last year and I want to highlight
a couple of things first we launched a
new and improved UI for browsing and
playback of media second we launched
support for search in media apps so that
a driver can easily find the exact song
or podcast that they're looking for
and third we launched an enabled support
for group messaging so it's much easier
to stay in touch with friends and family
when you're on the go with a voice
powered experience we also released an
update recently for wide screens where
Android auto can now offer a much better
seamless experience for ultra wide
screens as shown here you can also have
maps and media running side-by-side
allowing the driver to accomplish more
tasks easily while keeping their focus
on the road so beyond some of these
features we also continue to invest
deeply in our core UI for Android auto
yesterday we announced some big design
improvements to the Android auto
experience that make it easier for
consumers to see and access the apps and
information that they want so I'd like
to invite Ian Barlow one of our lead
designers who's been working on many of
these changes that come and share some
more about what we're doing here thanks
Mickey we have a lot of really big
changes coming to Android auto soon and
I'm so excited to show them to you today
but before I do I'd like to talk a
little bit about how we got to them give
you a little bit of the backstory you
know as Mickey mentioned Android auto
has really become an industry standard
for automotive infotainment experiences
people are actually basing their new car
purchase decisions on whether the car
has Android auto well that's amazing but
we also know that there's still room for
improvement and we haven't gotten
everything right along the way we've
heard from our users that there are some
core usability problems with the current
system and it hasn't really been updated
in the last four years and it feels kind
of out of date and so we've been
thinking about this a lot how do we
evolve the user experience of the
product to feel more intuitive and how
do we elevate the design language to
feel more modern and like it's actually
made for the car you know some of you
may even remember last year at i/o we
previewed some of the concepts that
we've been working on
well today I'm gonna go into a lot more
detail and show you specifically what's
coming next on Android auto we've
completely overhauled the design
language we've built a system that's
more scalable and flexible and adapts to
more screen sizes and inputs and we've
refined a lot of those usability issues
and crafted an experience that's much
more intuitive and feels like a natural
extension of your phone in the car
so let's start with the design language
you know for those of you that use
Android auto you probably know it looks
like an earlier version like earlier
material design product that's really
bright poppy colors that's kind of a
lighter UI theme and it looks pretty
googly but it also doesn't really like
fit that well in the car it looks a
little bit out of place and so we've
been thinking about that a lot and we we
set out to refine the design language we
wanted to make something that felt were
seamlessly integrated into the car and
so we drew a lot of our inspiration from
automotive interior design the dark
color palettes and neutral themes
sophisticated materials the way textures
and accent colors draw attention to core
functions but that the whole experience
is designed to sit back and focus the
drivers attention on the road and we
took that inspiration and we combined it
with the best of material design to
craft an all new Google design language
for driving a dark UI theme that looks
right at home in the car and so to do
that we actually adapted parts of
material design we took the gray values
that existed today and we expanded them
to create a richer spectrum in the dark
ranch
that helped us build a more flexible UI
and something that looks much more
sophisticated we even refined the
material accent blue to make sure that
it displayed properly in cars and met
contrast we've also improved the
legibility of the system by moving to
more extended typefaces like Roboto
regular and medium and even Google sans
we also layered that into a type scale
that's easily glanceable and adheres to
our strict driver distraction and safety
guidelines
and so all of this coalesces into a new
visual system that looks right at home
in the car minimizes distraction and it
looks gorgeous now this new system is
also designed to be much more scalable
and designed so that it can fit into the
wider and larger and taller screens that
are coming into cars today so the idea
is you can plug your phone into any car
and it always be recognizably Android
auto but it'll always also make the best
possible use of the screen that it's on
I'd as I was saying oh sorry
it also supports voice and any other
input your car supports whether it has a
touchscreen uses a rotary controller or
as Mickey was mentioning uses a touchpad
but this redesign went so much deeper
than aesthetics and scalability alone
we've also made great strides towards
improving the overall usability of the
system we've heard from people today
it's hard to switch media apps when
messages come in they don't know where
they go it's hard to find and that the
whole system feels like something that
has to be learned and doesn't feel as
intuitive as it could and so we asked
ourselves how can we improve that how
can we help people get started faster on
their drive how can we simplify the
kinds of key tasks that people do while
driving how do we provide the right
information at a glance and make it
easier for people to access their
content in their apps and create a more
intuitive experience that feels more
like your phone in the car
and so all of these things the new
design language better scalability
usability improvements or effectively
the building blocks of this new
experience and when you put them all
together here's what it looks like
a brand new version of Android auto
that's easier to use than ever for
drivers
it's a gorgeous new UI that provides the
right information at the right time and
for developers this is an all new system
that's going to increase exposure to
your products in the car and it also
lays the groundwork for future
innovation so let's take a closer look
first of all we've completely redesigned
the navigation bar to make it easier to
access your apps your notifications and
your google assistant it's quite a bit
simpler than it is today and we did this
partly so that we could develop a new
kind of system widget that lets you
control ongoing content while you're in
another app and so what that means is
you could be using maps to navigate and
still have one tap access to skip songs
in your media app to skip back or
forward in your podcast or audiobook you
can even control an ongoing phone call
all while keeping a full view of your
map on the screen and if you do leave
maps for a second let's say to find
something new to listen to well that
widget adapts itself so you'll always
see important next turn information on
screen this is a really powerful new
feature and it provides drivers with the
information they need at exactly the
right time we've been driving around
with this for the last few months and I
have to say it is a game changer tasks
that used to take three or four taps in
the car can now be completed with a
single tap and what's even better is
that if you're a developer who already
has a media app that runs on Android
auto this new widget feature will
automatically work with your app from
day one there's nothing extra you need
to do we're also making it faster and
more intuitive for drivers to access
their favorite Android auto apps through
this newly redesigned launcher this
address is another one of those key
usability concerns I'd mentioned earlier
where people have a hard time finding
the rest of their apps in the system and
for developers this also drive more
usage for your product because they'll
be displayed much more prominently in
the Android auto system so the launcher
is great for
started new experiences but what about
responding to things as they come into
the car well the new Android auto still
supports notifications as it does today
so you never miss out on a new phone
call as it comes in or a new message but
what's more as we've also moved these
into a new dedicated Notification Center
that's always a single tap away in the
navigation bar so when you're driving
you can focus on the road and you won't
have to worry about responding to that
message right away if it's not the right
time because you can always easily get
back to it with a single tap now in this
new Android auto system were also still
leveraging the same api's for both
notification based messaging apps as
well as our templatized media app
experiences so again if you're already
along for the journey with us and you've
developed an app either in media or
messaging that works for Android auto
today there's nothing new that you need
to do as part of this new system your
app will still work and as you can see
it'll look great like it was made for
the car we are so excited about this
update for Android auto it'll be
available this summer in all Android
auto enabled vehicles but in the
meantime please make sure to swing by
our sandbox for a demo in our Hyundai
Kona we'd love to show you more about it
now I'm going to hand it back to Mickey
who's going to tell you what else we're
doing to bring Android into cars
thank you in the new UI looks awesome
yeah please come check it out and we
cannot wait to share it with you
starting this summer I'd like to go back
now just for a second to our vision
statement and really focus on the
seamless part of the statement with the
phone powered UI that's running side by
side with the built-in or native
experience in the car we see clear seams
in the user experience where our driver
has to switch between the native system
and the phone system to be able to
accomplish all their tasks for example
you might be using the built-in system
to adjust a cabin temperature and then
you switch into Android auto when you
want to use Google Maps or Spotify so
also as infotainment expands into
multiple screens like in a cluster
display I was showing earlier and it
gets more and more deeply integrated
into the car it gets more challenging to
be able to create one unified seamless
experience just from the phone so we
knew that we had a lot of work ahead of
us to continue to enable this vision
statement of creating a unified seamless
completely seamless experience so a few
years ago we started to talk to car
makers about how we could work together
to create this unified seamless
experience not surprisingly many car
makers were already experimenting with
Android or using it in their cars for
infotainment but there was a lot of work
to be done to adapt Android from mobile
to the car so we started to invest at
that time in making Android a turnkey
solution that industry partners could
take and bring into the car easily
without having to make significant
changes without having to change any of
the core framework or api's that make
the Android platform so great for
developers today you may have seen some
of the demos and prototypes that we
showed the last couple years with
Android running under the hood and many
Google and third-party apps running on
top
one of the first partners who we spoke
with who got very excited about working
with us on this project was Volvo we
engaged with them a couple of years ago
and formally announced our partnership
last year to bring Android Google Maps
the Google assistant and the third-party
app ecosystem through the Google Play
Store to all of their cars Volvo in turn
introduced us to their performance an
electric brand Polestar and just a few
weeks ago at the Geneva Auto Show they
unveiled the Polestar 2 that you see
here this will be the first consumer
vehicle launching in 2020 the ship with
the seamless experience that brings
together Android Google Apps and the
third-party app ecosystem to tell you
more about the car the technology and
our partnership we asked Polestar CEO
Thomas Inge and lot to join us here
today Thomas has been the CEO of pole
star since June 2017 and also serves as
a chief design officer of Volvo Car
Corporation previously he was a senior
vice president of design at Volvo and
has been the inspiration behind Volvo's
award-winning design Renaissance for
years welcome Thomas
thank you thanks Mickey behind my name
is Thomas Englert I'm the CEO of pole
star pasta is the new electric car brand
from Sweden
we are the rebellious child of Volvo and
we want to make pole star the guiding
star of the new era in the automotive
industry
without standing design that is our
religion this is the Scandinavian pure
progressive design that we bring with
our great products and this is the pole
star to make you said it we launched it
a couple of weeks ago in Geneva and we
brought it here today to the Google i/o
we are very enthusiastic about the joy
and the fun that the electric propulsion
brings to the car industry and we take
the safety the protection of your life
very serious so we take the battery and
like a Lego brick we build it into a
very tight unit with car body and that
is the superb foundation for the
outstanding safety of our cars range 300
miles was a 78 kilowatt hours battery
and power 300 kilowatt on front and rear
axle 660 Newton meter so it's a very
powerful fast and fun to drive car for
us the seamless integration into your
digital life is very important so we
have the poster app which from the first
browse through the car configurator to
you know the offer of subscription of
our car and ordering on
services like to pickup and delivery all
that done through one app we supposed to
branch so the great design on the
exterior with iconic graphics and the
clear-cut architecture
it's not only outside its as well our
strong powerful point in the interior
and while I Drive that video here to you
with great details of our Scandinavian
interior I want to tell you another
story about what is great what you
experience inside the Polestar the
cardistry has promised for a long long
time navigation that would be intuitive
navigation that would be up-to-date and
we actually failed we failed big times
from car generation to car generation
same with voice recognition so we
supposed to - we knew we have to do
something radically different in that
field and we did we teamed up with
Google and it was a greater and it
thanks a lot Google it was an amazing
partnership and we I think it's Eve
something amazing here we put an
infotainment system that is powered by
Android into the car bringing built-in
apps and optimized for the car apps and
services for our customers and that
includes Google Assistant that includes
the Google Maps and of course the Google
Playstore all integrated into the car
so our customers they can enjoy the
superb artificial intelligence of the
Google assistant fast learning voice
recognition to operate all the great
apps and functions having the hands on
the steering wheel and having the eyes
on the road
using it all through voice activation
and I want to demonstrate to you a
couple of examples of how that works
so please hey goo will show us the way
to being the fastest route to pizzeria
Roma so you get the way without knowing
the name of the street without knowing
the town just say the restaurant where
you want to go another example connected
to living with an electric car hey
Google show charging stations nearby
showing results for charging stations
nearby so and that is a nice reassuring
list of charging stations that you get
so you can navigate you can plan your
day you can search for things all using
the time in your car efficiently without
being distracted I think that's really
great major improvement of safety while
using your car entertainment system out
of the Google Play Store you can
download the apps that you like into one
of the four tiles and of course you can
swap in between these tiles with the
apps the car is always connected so you
do not have to use your phone
the pulsar 2 software will be updated
over-the-air regularly so the our way
car will always stay up to date we have
pasta to standing in the sandbox please
come and have a look join the coding
sessions and from today on it's up to
you to develop new apps and be creative
come up with new great ideas for apps
used in the car visit our website we
have some inspiring proposals ideas how
apps could be used in the car in the
future so please join the community and
use the opportunities that we have with
the infotainment system operated by
powered by Android now I would end the
session you're thinking you for having
an opportunity to come on stage and
present and I will do that with a last
voice-activated action and that goes
like that Google please play at last on
Spotify sure
[Music]
let's come on
Thank You Thomas
we're very excited about the car and the
technology and bringing it to consumers
next year and thank you for bringing one
here for all of us to see as well I'm
looking forward to driving one very soon
too
but the clicker is not working there we
go
so in addition to pole star in Volvo we
also announced our partnership last year
with the Renault Nissan Mitsubishi
Alliance to bring Android and a third
party app ecosystem to their a global
range of cars and we're not gonna stop
there we know that having a large
footprint is very important for
developers to adapt your apps and
services for these cars so we continue
to work with the rest of the industry as
well
on further adoption I'm excited to say
that we're seeing a ton of interest in
momentum so please stay tuned for more
news on that as we finish up I want to
recap the three in-car products where
we're investing in offering users and
our partners a choice on the phone
screen itself you heard today about the
Google assistance driving mode that will
be the next step in evolution of the
Android auto phone screen experience
there's Android auto for the car screen
which since launching in 2015 has
virtually become an industry standard
and is on its way to being in more than
a hundred million cars and last but not
least the Android automotive OS our
in-car embedded platform that will be
coming to market next year with the
Polestar - and many more vehicles and
partners soon after so we covered a lot
today about what we're doing to bring
Android into cars Thank You Thomas again
for joining us from Sweden and sharing
your car with us Thank You Ian for
coming up and sharing the fantastic
insights behind the new Android auto UI
you can check out both the Polestar and
the Android auto new UI in our sandbox
today and the rest of the week here at
i/o also if you're interested in the
details of how to build apps for these
cars please join the dedicated developer
session tomorrow morning and check out
our office hours later today thank you
so much for joining us here today
[Music]